[Music]
raising funding especially in the
pandemic has been a huge challenge it's
completely different than what you're
used to
it's everything is remote there's no
in-person meetings um it's been quite
different but it's been an awesome
experience i really enjoyed doing it you
get to it's almost more efficient
because you don't have to travel to each
location where all these investors are
now you can kind of stay in your office
in your home
be able to talk to you know 10 20 really
interesting companies that are
potentially good partners for you
and do so in a more efficient way almost
what's been really exciting is that it's
been great to be able to share my story
share the story of our company being
able to you know grow so quickly with so
many different unique investors that
also bring their own
insights and and and ability to help us
grow
to these meetings and uh what's been
really exciting is that we raised our
series a about four months ago we were
able to raise 160 million dollars to
fund our vision what's even more
exciting is that round was over
subscribed by 300
so right now we're actually in the
process of raising our series b and yeah
everything is going super quickly and
it's it's just really exciting raising
capital has been the least favorite part
of my job if i'm going to be honest and
i think that is very prominent again
amongst like founders so fundraising was
very hard i'm not even going to
sugarcoat it and especially one where
female founders two were
underrepresented like minority founders
three were selling dresses which doesn't
really resonate with a lot of
predominantly male vcs in silicon valley
so we've definitely got a lot of
pushback in the very beginning we were
raising a small round for a precede and
we've always gotten
a lot of backhanded comments of like oh
this industry is like
not big enough this market's too small
who really buys like dresses
like how many times do people buy
dresses or are dresses really over a
hundred dollars so we've gotten those
and we've even gotten things that were
very judgey
and we've gotten asked like oh
who built your app for you when me and
my co-founder are sitting there and my
co-founder is fully technical she's a
software engineer from pinterest and she
built everything herself so which is
very very impressive but still their
assumption is that because we're women
we're female founders that we didn't
build our app that were not technical
so it was definitely a struggle every
single meeting we walked into whether
it's in person or zoom we had to make
sure we brought our a plus plus game we
had to
prove ourselves so much more than our
male founder counterparts and even you
know for me i went to berkeley my
co-founder went to penn like these are
great schools we've worked at uber
facebook and pinterest great companies
still isn't enough when we bring up hey
we used to do pageants hey we're
tackling the dress industry it's almost
as if those facts those statements about
what our business is completely
obliterate
everything that we've kind of worked
hard for and everything that we are
so credentials almost don't matter as
much for female founders that's what
i've noticed
it's good that we had them because it
would have been a lot worse if we did
not
and so
i think that we just have to work twice
three times as hard as male founders in
this industry i'm in a super capital
intensive industry where
constantly you have to raise capital
everything
you know down from the service network
we have to build out to you know
millions of dollars in tooling and
equipment for our manufacturing line
is so capital intensive that you have to
be able to get ahead of that especially
to remain competitive and to succeed so
definitely capital is a challenge
um making sure we had a product market
fit was a challenge
making sure we had the right partners
was a huge challenge you know because
you you want to be careful
with who you work with you know as much
as you know what you're building or what
market you're in raising capital is
absolutely exhausting you know you're
constantly selling yourself right when
you're a founder you're selling your
customers you're selling your investors
you're selling your team
right um in some common vision
i'm super fortunate that we have amazing
investors with very long term time
horizon that really get it um but
having to pitch and constantly
right you know answer questions and um
be challenged right
it toughens you
but you know it's definitely
a challenging thing to do
so our fundraising today has
happened very quickly i think is a
byproduct of pivoting you know in a
global pandemic
and living in a remote world i didn't
get the chance to get to know investors
as deeply as i might have in a
non-remote world
and what i think that forced is
a whole lot of trust right trust from
the investors that someone who they met
six days ago is
you know worthy of millions of dollars
and trust for me that someone i met six
days ago can have voting power in this
company right and as someone who i want
to represent and you know embody real to
the public and that's that hasn't been
natural for me i think i
really
like deeply getting to know folks and
haven't gotten that opportunity i
haven't even met them in person to this
day right so all to say
it has been
an experience that asks for a whole lot
of trust for fundraising
initially it was pretty difficult
because i was mostly an outsider in tech
so i took a lot of we went to
accelerator
met some people
went back to la got more familiar with
the la ecosystem and eventually met a
couple
angel investors but even before then
um my parents and my best friend
actually wrote their first check into
the company
my parents used their own savings my
best friends used all of what he had
and wrote three hundred thousand dollar
check together into into the company to
get us started and then it got easier
from there as we can prove out based on
our financials and our product we have
more to show we
were at this point where we were getting
further and further behind on orders
where we just could not place the orders
far enough in advance and everything
like that so we were very aware that we
were holding the company back that
levi and robbie were holding this
company back from the potential it could
achieve so it was that realization that
we knew that we had to go and find
another partner to complement us because
we had two great skill sets but we met
laxed the massive amount of capital in
order to really pour the gasoline on
this first we just engaged with a
investment banking group to help us run
a process uh that was a ton of fun um we
kind of got to be like the belle of the
ball because we had a ton of growth so
when we first did that uh there was just
so much demand and we really got to be
picky with who we chose to work with and
we really wanted to find someone that
looked at the way we were doing business
and kind of in the same light i'm not
going to lie to you it's definitely
not
butterflies and rainbows in my book i
have a page on what it's like to be on
that path and it's like a little gold
road focusing on the process is like one
of the most important things because it
can be really hard to be
in this
in this time period for like an extended
amount of time focusing on the process
the outcomes will come focused on
building great relationships that will
be around for decades
i think um that's been really important
to us so community first
and thinking long term have have been
like the things that i've learned
through this process we've raised about
38 million to date about a 11 million
seed another 27 million series a
we had a relatively easy time i would
say raising the seed because i was
fortunate i was already in silicon
valley um once people got excited about
the idea it's taken years and years of
insight and thinking about aging to kind
of understand all the pieces need to
come together and why explicitly i'm
working on the aging problem this way
and it's very hard to communicate in a
30 minute pitch right so you have to
believe that you can build a dog aging
drug that it's a billion dollar market
that this is the best way to get to
human aging drugs that there's an aging
drug for human markets and that i can do
it right i think another thing i really
learned was how to pattern match well to
what competence looks like in those
fields so the seed was really kind of a
test of learning how to do that and
learning how to seem competent series a
was another test in terms of
doing that but for a different audience
in addition to like really well
communicating the path to what i'm
trying to build which what i'm trying to
build is an aging company right so it's
a it's a it's a long path
um and not something that people have
thought about before and there's no
objective metrics to say if we're
successful or not so really has to
convince people that i'm competent and
my team's competent and that we can
execute when we initially started
specult i started with my co-founder we
used to work together so she'd seen the
problem firsthand and we initially
decided to just raise capital from
friends and family so we raised a little
over three hundred thousand dollars and
we thought that we would eventually just
launch the product bring it to market
and bootstrap it in some ways what we
realized though is that we're competing
in a space where other players other
competitors have reached hundreds of
millions of dollars and we simply
weren't going to be able to compete
without some capital
with that said you know in our broad
space we're the only female founding
company which i didn't realize until
after we started the company and
generally speaking in enterprise tech
there are still very few female ceos
luckily we're starting to see it more in
consumer tech but with that
it was a pretty intimidating experience
at first
i had to unlearn some of the more
masculine traits that i'd really adopted
working in real estate and financial
tech and instead of really leaning into
like what would make me unique as an
entrepreneur because i knew that
investors
weren't used to seeing founders that
looked like me or that looked like my
co-founder and so you know at first it
was a challenge really figuring out you
know
not just what is the process of raising
capital
but how do i stand out how do i really
sell that vision and stay true and
authentic to who i am and the feminine
leadership that that i feel strongly um
called towards so luckily we we found
some incredible investors we've raised
15 million dollars to date and
uh on our on our way to raise a lot more
here soon we've raised about 70 million
dollars today when you really need money
you can't raise money and when you don't
need money money gets thrown at you sort
of the dynamic which is a terrible
dynamic to be in as an entrepreneur
because in the early days my co-founder
and i we bootstrapped it and then we
went to y combinator and then we raised
our seed or a and r b within eight
months during the pandemic so it was
about 70 million dollars in about eight
months and
it's easy when you have a good business
but again we didn't we didn't need the
money after we did by combinator and so
just became easier and uh which is an
oxymoron you think the larger the check
size the larger the round the harder it
is to raise
it hasn't been our experience so far
it's a great business since that helps
but it's been easier
you